bene a tutti ragazzi venuti questo video
io sono qui oggi saluto con fair e
mentre si interrompe ma scusate avete
fatto il test ma che te ne tagliano
parte guardaparco che dobbiamo fare
inizia allora abbiamo fatto 66 missioni
disagio simulator 2
ormai sono spaventato a morte su queste
pazienti quanto sono spaventati a
vederci bene
mamma mia perdendo meno di mamma mia
raga questa secondo me la vedo dura dal
nome andiamo su allora buongiorno non so
se è più paso lo più operazione vera si
sono già esibiti in quanti fusibili già
non lo so mettiamo le giovani si parte
così finora è facile finora è facile ma
dovette spostare dalla libreria e vabbè
io non me l'aspettavo mai così eccoci
qui intanto la cartella finalmente vedo
che c'è un po di casino è stato operato
ma perché allora veda il bottone ha
funzionato si è già un miracolo
buongiorno allora aspetta che devono
posizionare il computer così già capiamo
dove dobbiamo però è cosa molto
difficile da capire e non di non
capitano anche praticamente che dobbiamo
togliere le travi di legno guardate
questo cartello acqua sono qua sono poi
vedi che dice di spostare a sì sì sì sì
certo c'erano pieno inutile il mondo
certo quello sicuro io adesso vedo due
slot dei fusibili quindi 31 qui ok ok
mandato perché non succede nulla
l'aveva che ne so io di quello che abbia
un computer solo fa una volta ci
dobbiamo mettere vabbè facciamone 1 e ma
non c'è l'altro computer hanno sì che
c'è qualche mese fa ha detto che lo sta
già ma come facciamo raga impossibile o
ce l'ho fatta che facciamo ma sono
uguali ragazzine subito caro non me lo
faccio ripeto le operazioni che dovevamo
fare solo i denti non colta voli sei
sicuro da rendere il torino tranquillo
la testa la stacco solo con attrezzi
quelli liberato quando i denti aveva si
parte la li ha tagliati storia no ho
sbagliato mira scusa
ok apposta poi l'ho fatto l'ho fatto
l'ho fatto
sapete che adesso che riesco a fare sta
cosa quindi se avete bisogno di notte e
ieri no ai piedi ha funzionato
allora io ho perso l'occasione di leva
che magari sta morendo non lo sappiamo
nulla della loro vita vedere guerra le
grigliate un po no si fa si mettono lì è
accaduto di tutto l'oriente comunque
essere decidendo a per il territorio ora
no è un po stonato e sino a un po più
fortunati varela io sono arriva
completamente allora venite come
l'italia la gara non vieni vieni via
abbiamo abbastanza nuova ci sono
approccio sinistro gamba sinistra testa
e braccio destro e riproduttiva e prendi
tutto che qua a noli sto buttando lì
sotto ok quindi non ti do buttare in
giro e che stava andando non stanno
cadendo solo al giorno
ciao come fa da sempre parco ieri è
arrivato tutto scusa tutto buttato
stiamo facendo scendere ai qualsiasi
cosa
no eh vabbè ma quale dei due tagli alla
gamba sinistra tutti e due in realtà
tutti e due di rifare lo stesso e vedere
se lo piglia sono gemelli anche nei
problemi che mi fa venire tagliare la
testa di non sa quale karma quale gamba
sinistra
la sua la mia la sua web ritagliare
quella quella pagina immagini sono
mestre team anti masci se questo
discorso lo fanno in sala operatoria
davvero ho fatto quello che ho fatto
perché appoggiamo questa cosa tagliare
anche l'altro già che ci siamo scusati
aspetta aspetta aspetta cosa mi taglia
rete è l'altra gamba giacche sono carico
come posiziona la rai rai aspetta che
riprenderà siringhe peres prostatica
inail
siamo sempre in pericolo quando cioè le
gambe insomma un'altra vialetto ma gli
arti staccati perché se non di
confondiamo ieri tenerli attaccare anche
arti giusti tipo le teste le metterei
essere mettiamo con la quale attestava
una qualità stava all'altro è usuale su
valida di uno più bello non so io ho
staccato bracciolo e le siringhe che sia
ma l'ho fatto ma non l'ho fatto che gli
ho messo aspetta forse la posto niente
ha posto come ho detto ok io ho fatto
ok ho fatto cosa manca a caso limite
fino e vabbè allora è come vanno gli
intestini intestino sano e vero nome è
l'asta intestino crasso intestino tenue
e marice 0 prova prevale no e gli sono
già giu parlare 1 in casa al loro
interno è ok noi divertire diverso
questo è il tenue sinistra il tenue e
quello lo so perché quello che ci hai tu
con blu blu blu e tenue no ok quello
questo qua interventi su questo io l'ho
messo un bob che va un bob che viene
veniva fatta allora ma non gli è tolto
quello malato è mai andato bene
no non è un bar che obama allora vedi
che ti segna quello giusto ma col malato
da togliere beh allora prendi un bisturi
gli ho messo due intestini ma poi
scusami ma non c'è ma non c'è quello
malato no rimetti per ogni giocatore può
che lasciano così ok è però lo sapio a
melo da buono ok e dobbiamo togliere
quello blu all altro arrivo tanto prima
con la sega per sbaglio tra vejano già
previsti e già fatto e che doveva
incredibile la gara gli studi dove
troviamo la sega riuso di nuovo allora
quando posto semifinale fisco che l'app
è amara a quel punto aveva addirittura
apriamo un serrato e senza volerlo
quindi figuriamoci un bisturi manco a
pagarlo
no infatti incontra su amazon se c'è la
spesa dello stato guarda guarda e
incredibile precisione è veramente
assuma non sapevi farlo mai prima
siringa piena prendi questa l'ho
appoggiata ragazzina dai capelli basha
iori attacco a quello staccare dovere
questa ma sicuro allora decise ferro del
1000 straw guarda piccino che allora
aspettate mamma me contano ritirate
perché siamo all'ultima cosa ai problemi
di ci sia anche senza dio mio addio ai
ecco
[Applauso]
anche sponsor schizzinoso non staccare
questo braccio bravo è stato il
divertentissimo siamo bravi a questa
segala arrivederci
no sono io dietro come jason adesso che
ti uccido nella lobby abbiamo finito ci
vogliono far fare a cielo quasi
rispettare
ecco s'intravede ha lanciato la sega va
bene e stato divertente ragazzi molto
strano e divertente i ragazzi questa è
l'operazione di oggi veramente
incasinata però alla fine ce l'abbiamo
fatta lo stesso l'importante è vincere e
salvare bob come in tutte le puntate
disagio si prendono che trovate anche su
canalis tfr e noi come sempre ragazzi
dopo vi siete iscritti al canale cilia
alle pressioni delle ragazze
[Musica]